unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.comground
okay it is time for a weekly
coronavirus update i think weekly is
sort of the right
timing to do these we're now not really
following day to day
data but more looking at things week
over week and looking at trends and
changes to cases and deaths and
vaccinations so let's jump right in
things are still looking continually
better they're looking better than last
week on average but there's now sort of
a word of caution about
some of the last few days of data and
again because we're looking week over
week i don't think we should read too
much into it now but i'll explain
momentarily from the standpoint of
coronavirus
cases cases are now down 72 percent
from their average peak which took place
on january 11th
on january 11th our seven day average
was 255
000 new cases per day when we think back
to
um june of 2020
when dr fauci said if we're not careful
we might get to a hundred thousand cases
a day
and many deniers said that'll never
happen and we got to 100
000 and 150 and 200 and we were
averaging 255
000 new cases a day uh the week of
january 11th
we are now down from that peak by
72 72 decline in new daily cases
to about 70 000 per day but
and here's that word of caution the
decline
has leveled off in the last few days and
there was even a slight
average day-to-day uptick yesterday
now a lot of people have been asking and
emailing me and tweeting to me
is this an actual reversal our case is
now going to go up
i don't think so i think it's possible
that
if indeed the vaccines are shown to be
ineffective against the primary variants
that in a couple of months cases could
actually start going up in earnest
i don't think that that is going to be
the case but that's not what we're
talking about now what is going on right
now is that
because of the terrible weather in much
of the country last week testing
and reporting of cases was slowed down
so most likely there were declines that
were reported late last week
which were bigger than the real declines
because
weather stopped a bunch of testing and
reporting
and now as the reporting gets caught up
and people who should have been tested
friday saturday sunday but weren't
because of bad weather are getting
tested and are coming back positive
and so the numbers are kind of leveling
off and appearing a bit higher i don't
think
this is a real reversal i think this is
an artifact of the reporting changes
because of the weather
now in terms of deaths the numbers have
also improved dramatically
unfortunately the numbers were so bad
when it comes to deaths that
even these improved numbers are still
completely tragic but deaths are down
38 percent from their mid-january highs
deaths were peaked at 3 400 per day
they're down to about 2100 per day now
2100 per day is outrageous it's an
outrageous tragedy every single day
but it is a decline of 38
and similar to cases a small uptick in
the last couple of days
also believed to be because of lower
reporting
due to the bad weather late last week
which is now
recovering and the data will sort of be
shuffled around and and
i think we'll be back to kind of normal
day-to-day tracking within another 48 to
72 hours we'll know
in the next four to six days whether
there really is a reversal here
cases and deaths leveling or even even
going up a bit
or whether this is just a reporting
artifact and cases and deaths will
continue
down now much like case and death
reporting was slowed down because of the
bad weather
so were vaccinations slowed down we had
actually gotten
up to averaging about 1.7 million
shots per day but because of the bad
weather
and important to understand the bad
weather affected vaccinations
in the states with the bad weather like
texas for example
but the bad weather also affected
shipments of vaccines to
more of the country and last week we saw
vaccinations per day
a drop from 1.7 million a day to 1.4
million a day now that's still
much higher from where we were um
january 20th for example
it's not high enough and dr fauci says
he's confident
that the missed doses are going to be
made up for
in the next week or so let's hope that
happens and obviously
we're following that number very closely
the three numbers we're looking at
closely now are cases
deaths and vaccinations hospitalizations
also
an important indicator to look at now
vaccines
in terms of vaccine news and important
studies
as i said yesterday in our segment about
vaccine alarmism
remember vaccine alarmism is not
anti-vaxx
vaccine alarmism is something else we
described yesterday
people just being uh unnecessarily
negative about the impact of these
vaccines
although the effect on transmission
by uh being vaccinated was not studied
by moderna and pfizer
we are getting more and more early data
from the united kingdom and
israel which gets us closer and closer
to being able to say
fully vaccinated people are
transmitting are able to transmit
coronavirus to a much lesser degree
two studies one from the uk says that
two doses of the pfizer vaccine cut
transmission risk by 86 percent
now normal caveats this is a preprint
this wasn't studied in the phase three
trials by moderna and pfizer
so it is now being studied pre-print uk
data
says transmission down 86 percent among
fully vaccinated people
a study from israel found an 89
reduction in transmission among fully
vaccinated people
this is good news which still needs to
be confirmed in peer-reviewed settings
until it is confirmed we should not be
acting belligerently
once vaccinated now as far as vaccine
supply right now and this gets to
one of the main questions which is when
will person a
person b person c be able to get a
vaccine
it will vary state to state we have seen
very uneven rollouts
in some states versus others as far as
vaccine
supply it looks like the united states
will have enough
vaccine for full vaccination
of 130 million people by the end of
march
now that's five weeks away but remember
that it takes up to five weeks to be
fully vaccinated what i mean by that is
with the pfizer vaccine
you have 21 days between dose one and
two with the moderna vaccine it's 28
days between
dose one and two and you're not
considered fully protected
until seven days after your second dose
so if you
get the moderna vaccine if you can get
it
by march 31st and let's imagine you get
an appointment
you get your second dose on april 28th
and that means you are not considered
fully protected until uh
roughly uh may 5th that would be okay so
it's about a 35 day period from when you
get it until
when you're considered fully vaccinated
however there is more good news and that
is that the third vaccine the johnson
johnson vaccine
is on the way today it has been endorsed
for emergency use authorization by fda
staff it now needs to go through
the kind of final final process for
emergency use authorization
that is a one dose vaccine
the good news is one dose makes
logistics far simpler
and uh x number of doses is good for
twice as many vaccinations right if you
have 10 million doses but everybody
needs two you can vaccinate 5 million
people
if you have 10 million doses and people
only need one you can vaccinate 10
million people
the cautious possible downside on the
jnj vaccine
supply is unclear and i i think we'll
just leave it there because
unclear basically tells you everything
we need to know we just don't know yet
how much supply of that will be
available how quickly so
i think where the facts lead us is to
continued cautious optimism
as far as variants go we'll be
interviewing dr eric topel again
soon about the effectiveness of these
vaccines against the three most
prevalent variants that's a topic of
concern right now it's looking okay
and uh we'll have more information about
that soon and in our interview with
dr eric topple all right this this is
something very different
that i'm going to do and let me know if
you think that that this is uh
interesting for the show and whether
this is instructive as many of you know
and many people are mad about this i
don't talk about politics with viewers
via email i'm so busy doing the show
that i
i can't respond to political questions
via email or engage in that way
at this point we get about 6 000 emails
comments
tweets facebook posts and the like every
single day
we would need multiple full-time people
if the idea was to sort of like engage
meaningfully with every every comment
but
every once in a while if there's
something that i think will be
instructive i will sort of jump in
and get involved and indeed
i received an email yesterday morning
from an anti-vaccine individual spouting
conspiracy theories
and i decided to engage i decided to
actually
let's see where they are getting their
information
how did they come to hold the beliefs
that they have and so i'm protecting
uh her email address and and and last
name
but i am going to go through a
conversation i had via email
with an anti-vaxxer named amy now amy
wrote to me yesterday morning
with the subject a concerned viewer and
amy said
about vaccines just curious how you
could deceive others when it comes to
the covid
and the vaccines i'm well aware that you
know
it's all a scam and the so-called
vaccines
are causing deaths now there's there's
probably five things there to look at
the idea that i know that it's a scam
what the virus or vaccination
the so-called vaccine refers to people
who say
these aren't actually vaccines causing
deaths refers to people who believe
it is the vaccine causing people to die
rather than covet itself
so there's a lot here but let's let's
get a big picture view of what she's
saying
amy goes on is money that important to
you that you have to go along with this
now no who would even pay me to save the
vaccines
you know i i really got a vaccine nobody
paid me to do that
nobody's paying me to say that it was
great uh
i i don't even know who would be willing
to give me money to do that
amy goes on people are starting to
despise you
well people have despised me for a long
time that's not not she's right about
that but that's not new
and you don't have to believe me but all
traders involved in this scam
will see a prison cell it's already
mentioned in a couple lawsuits i know of
so keep on with your nonsense and you
will see so i actually decided
to write back to amy and i said
no one has died from the vaccine we will
not
spread dangerous propaganda on our show
to which amy wrote me back very quickly
i have proof i also have proof from cdc
documents
we are being played the fact that you
don't even
ask about the proof i have proves
you are involved in this scam so up
until this point the allegation is
because i've not asked her for the proof
i'm part of the scam now i actually
uh want to see where she is getting
these ideas i want to see what documents
what websites what is it
that these anti-vaxx conspiracy folks
are basing their ideas on so i wrote
back
okay send it send me the stuff i want to
see
the proof and amy wrote back
first without even addressing the fact
that i've asked for the information
saying you know exactly what's up there
are cdc documents admitting we're being
played
lawsuits filed saying we're being played
mike pompeo was asked one time if
coveted was a hoax and he wouldn't
answer
now that was for political reasons that
that's not you know mike pompeo was
secretary of state
he doesn't know anything about
immunology or epidemiology
and she goes on to say as for the fake
vacs why would fauci get caught faking
getting it
i have that proof too this is a
conspiracy that
dr fauci pretended to be vaccinated but
that the
he wasn't really injected and then she
finishes her email by saying there's all
kinds of death reports and the list of
proof goes on and on you do know
all this now of course
i want the proof now so i simply wrote
back to amy
please send me the documents so i can
review them lawsuits
and documents and now amy says
slowing down her responses a little bit
taking a little more time between
responses amy says
i'll get the info together now however i
feel like this is a trick
because i know how you people work you
all want to know what info we have so
you can scrub it from the internet so
this is interesting first evidence of my
malfeasance was that i didn't ask for
the proof
now it's suspicious that i am asking for
the proof and of course
the idea that i can just have things
scrubbed from the internet
you know we're now going many levels
deep amy says i'm not stupid and i don't
trust anyone
there's no way you don't know this
especially doing what you do while i'm
getting the info
here is the name of one attorney dealing
with a lawsuit reiner
rolmick and a question still is why
wouldn't mike pompeo answer when asked
if covid was a hoax
why would dr fauci fake getting the
so-called
vaccine there's no way you wouldn't know
what's up so i wrote back again i'm
remaining very
calm and i just said it's no trick i
want to see the info amy writes back
i'm getting the info together and like i
said reiner
romick is one of the attorneys and he
admits
it's fraud again we don't know what is
fraud
little more time goes by amy sends me
another email
i just ran across this about the
inventor of the tests they're using for
covid
he tells you it can't detect if you're
sick
notice how they remove the video because
it's truth now i don't know what video
she's referring to
but the article she sent has nothing to
do with proof of people dying from the
vaccine
they aren't lawsuit documents it's
merely an article which says
pcr tests can't tell you if you are
actually ill with something and we know
that
and that has nothing to do with covid
pcr tests are designed to tell you
is a particular signal present in a
swab uh you might physically have some
virus particles in you and you might not
actually be sick that's not news of any
kind
and so i wrote back at this point and i
said amy
you said you had proof the vaccine is
killing people
this is an article about testing can you
send the articles you mentioned
about vaccines as well as the lawsuits
and i never heard from amy again
now there are certainly some anti-vaxx
conspiracy theorists who would have
things to send me
and if they did i would evaluate the
sources in the past they're
very disreputable websites you know
natural news
type sites and things like this but this
is a great example
of the types of thinking we're dealing
with where
me wanting the information or not
wanting it both
are part of the conspiracy finding the
videos she's referring to
would be proof of the conspiracy but if
she can't find them
that's proof that someone removed them
in order to cover up the conspiracy
and so i think the takeaway for me is
obviously
you know i this this took an hour out of
my day
it's not plausible to do what this is a
retail
strategy to disabuse people of these
notions now
because amy ultimately couldn't find any
of the things she said she was going to
send me does did she change her views
even
probably not what i did probably didn't
even change her views and this really
goes to
the difficulty in dealing with this type
of conspiratorial thinking we've done
interviews with experts on
conspiratorial thinking
and conspiracism and they pointed to the
same thing
let me know what else maybe we can learn
from this but certainly
an illuminating moment in illuminating
just how much of an uphill battle
this is and uh i'd love to hear from you
you can find me
on twitter at d pacman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation
is one of the biggest problems that our
society faces and online filter bubbles
make the problem worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first
news comparison platform that lets you
compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering
a story i use it myself i love it
because it lets me easily see how
different news outlets are manipulating
a story to fit their own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is viewer and
listener supported
independent media consider grabbing a
membership at joinpacman.com
you'll get daily commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show just for you
as well as the daily bonus show every
day we've got the broadcast show podcast
that's what this
is and then we do another show where
producer pat
joins me to discuss even more news and
stories that one
is just for our members and you can sign
up at joinpakman.com and of course
feel free to use the coupon code
better21 if you would like a
discount this is very interesting we now
have
a full month into joe biden's presidency
a full month out of donald trump's
presidency there's a new economist
yougov poll that looked at favorability
versus unfavorability
for a number of the most well-known
american political figures and the key
takeaway
is that bernie sanders and joe biden by
almost
exactly the same degrees are the
most relatively well liked
national elected officials in the united
states the poll was released yesterday
it found that 49 of americans
have a very or somewhat favorable view
of bernie sanders while joe biden
has a 50 mostly
or somewhat favorable view when you look
at the
unfavorable so bernie's 49
favorable 39 unfavorable
joe biden on the other hand is 50
favorable
42 unfavorable these are both
essentially
within the margin of error and they tell
us that
right now in the united states the most
i mean i don't think popular is the
wrong word to use the most popular the
most
well-liked net favorable elected
officials
are the current president joe biden as
well as senator bernie sanders
uh the furthest left member of the
united states senate now for a
comparison
vice president kamala harris has a
slightly smaller
net favorability so net favorability is
favorability minus unfavorability bernie
at 49.39
is at plus 10. biden at 5042 is at plus
eight and kamala harris at 48 favorable
43 unfavorable is at plus
five um someone like alexandria
ocasio-cortez
also pulled at plus one favorability and
that's maybe not surprising aoc very
well liked among those that like her
very much disliked among those that
dislike her
mitch mcconnell one of the least liked
politicians in the country net
favorability
for mcconnell was minus 48
with only 17 percent of the country
viewing mcconnell favorably 65 percent
viewing him unfavorably uh joe manchin
minus 11 joe manchin the most
conservative member
of senate democrats among the democratic
members of the senate the most
conservative
and uh these are very interesting
numbers for a few different reasons when
donald trump was president of the united
states
he never reached 50 percent approval now
approval remember is different than
favorability trump never reached 50
approval and left office with the lowest
approval rating
in the history of the polling era for
any president
joe biden came in in different polls
had the highest initial approval
of any president in the last 28 years
joe biden with initial approval
one poll had him at 58 percent another
had him at 63 percent
really really high numbers and
the fact that when it comes to
favorability
we are also seeing joe biden be one of
the most
well-liked american politicians tells us
that these numbers these one-off numbers
63
approval 69 approval on handling of
kovid
80 support for his mask again to call it
a mandate is a bit much but
federal mandate plus uh national
recommendation
uh these are not flukes and these are uh
the entire package of numbers makes a
lot of sense now
the question we have to get to is so
what
what is joe biden now going to do i've
been talking now
for we're into week five on covet relief
and the belief is that we are getting
closer to covet relief
did joe biden over promise by saying
checks would go out right away yeah
probably
but it's time to just do it joe biden
has the highest initial approval
and one of the highest favorabilities
right now of any
american politician the country mostly
wants the covid relief bill
what are we waiting for here given that
republicans have made it clear from the
beginning their goal is only to obstruct
they proposed instead of a 1.9 trillion
dollar package
this pathetic tiny package 600 billion
cutting a whole bunch of the key
elements of the bill out
what are we waiting for joe biden has
the approval rating
joe biden has the favorability joe biden
has the american people's view on
covet relief on his side what are we
waiting for at this point it's time to
do it
and i am we're i think we're just a
couple of days maybe even one day
from the next gallup tracking poll with
biden's approval
i'm curious to see where it is but i
don't know of any reason
to wait any longer for just passing
coveted relief via budget reconciliation
let every republican vote against it if
that's what they want to do
i don't think they will because they
know it's popular with their own
constituents
ted cruz is now clearly even more
disgusting than we thought
and we thought ted cruz was pretty damn
disgusting
after his recent cancun cruise fiasco
where he
fled the country amid a power outage in
his state of texas to go sit on the
beach
in cancun ted cruz has now been pictured
scrolling through his phone paying no
attention
to senate hearings yesterday about the
january 6th
trump capital riots um
this is a picture of ted cruz
uh very very busy on his phone as
testimony about
exactly what happened on january 6th is
taking place
ted cruz completely disrespecting the
hearings he doesn't care
and here is video you will hear
a testimony going on and then you will
see the camera cut to ted cruz who is on
his phone
he's tapping in a way it almost looks
like he's playing a game maybe booking a
flight to cancun or
acapulco i don't know exactly what he's
doing let's take a look at this
based on the intelligence that we
received we plan for an increased level
of violence at the capitol
and that some participants may be armed
but none of the intelligence we received
predicted what actually occurred
yeah i don't know i don't know if he's
trying to book flight somewhere warm
i don't know if he's playing a game i
don't know if he's tapping out a text
to that group of friends that were
really pleased with the 309
a night rate that they were going to get
at whatever hotel in cancun they
went to last week ted cruz just
cannot stop embarrassing himself
almost daily at this point in time not
the only person by the way i don't want
to only focus on ted cruz here in our
coverage of these hearings yesterday
not the only person disrespecting these
hearings into the trump riots
radical republican senator ron johnson
again ron johnson just one of the worst
he took his question and answer period
and used it to float some ridiculous
conspiracy theory about how the january
6th riots were actually done
by everybody other than trump supporters
people pretending to be trump supporters
left wingers whatever
but they weren't really trump supporters
take a look at this
of people i passed or who passed me
along constitution avenue some were
indignant
and contemptuous of congress but not one
appeared angry or incited to riot
many of the marchers were families with
small children many were elderly
overweight or just plain tired or frail
traits not typically attributed to the
riot prone many wore pro-police shirts
or carried pro-police black and blue
flags
although the crowd represented a broad
cross-section of americans mostly
working class by their appearance and
manner of speech
some people stood out a very few didn't
share the jovial friendly earnest
demeanor of the great majority
some obviously didn't fit in and he
describes
four different types of people
plainclothes militants
agents provocateurs fake trump
protesters
and then disciplined uniform column of
attackers i think these are the people
that
probably plan this he goes on the d.c
metropolitan police were their usual
professionally detached cells
standing on curbs or at street crossings
and exchanging occasional greeting for
marchers
when we crossed first street northwest
to enter the capitol grounds where the
capitol police had jurisdiction
i noticed no police at all several
marchers expressed surprise
they opened to seem like a courtesy
gesture from congress which controls
security
they weren't actual trump supporters
they were
provocateurs they were fake trump
protesters
and this is very similar to the it was
actually antifa in disguise
antifa with trump shirts and trump flags
and trump hats and some of them armed
and they even played the they they
really acted all day
going to the trump rally and cheering it
was all an act
that's what we are led to believe
believe and
i i don't even know how much more we
have to talk about this it's
horrifying and delusional that we still
have members of the senate floating this
idea
but the january 6th trump riots were
really really simple
it wasn't antifa it wasn't mostly a
muslim crowd it wasn't mostly a mexican
crowd
it wasn't the lgbt community it wasn't
socialists
it wasn't biden supporters or obama
supporters or bernie sanders supporters
it wasn't black lives matter it was
trump supporters
who mostly are white christian and male
now there are some exceptions
okay uh it wasn't most white people most
white people weren't
trump rioters it wasn't most men most
men wanted nothing to do with the riots
it wasn't most christians but those who
were there were disproportionately
men white and christian but most
importantly
they were trump supporters that's it
no more conspiracy theories hypotheses
or wild speculations are needed to
determine who it was
that was there on that day but ron
johnson doesn't care and he's going to
keep it going and we'll have more
coverage from yesterday's
senate hearings about the trump riots on
our instagram page you can follow us on
instagram
at david pakman show the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at join
joinpackman.com that's
join p a k m a n dot com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
republican senator mitt romney is not
someone that i go to when i need advice
about
anything he's not someone that i agree
with on policy
almost ever except for maybe some
completely uncontroversial
small things but he has
done one thing right during the last
couple of years which is for the most
part he just
tells things as they are even when they
are about the republican party
and uh mitt romney predicted yesterday
that
donald trump would easily win the 2024
republican presidential nomination
if indeed he tries to win it in 2024
and this coincides exactly with what the
polling has indicated that we've looked
at over the last month which is that at
least for now and things can change
between now and 2022 between 2022 and
2024
but for now the vast majority of the
republican party
is behind donald trump and the 2024
nomination
is his for the taking if indeed he wants
it
mitt romney said that he is quote sure
that trump will at least play a role
in the republican party in the coming
years pointing out that he is by far
the largest voice and big impact a big
impact
in the party and that quote i expect he
will continue playing a role i don't
know if he'll run in 2024 or not
but if he does i'm pretty sure he will
win the nomination romney did point out
as we've been pointing out that things
can change between now and 2024
but that for the time being quote i look
at the polls and the polls
show that among the names being floated
as pot as potential contenders
in 2024 if you put president trump in
there among republicans
he wins in a landslide i think that that
is
absolutely and completely correct and
unless something changes
if trump wants it the nomination is
likely to be his in 2024. now what is it
that could change and i think this is
the most important thing to think about
well a couple different things could
change
number one trump could change things by
starting his own party and we've talked
about this before
for now trump has such a following
within the republican party
that if he were to say i'm leaving the
party and starting my own
64 percent of republicans say they would
leave with him now
i don't believe 64 percent actually
would
i think when it came down to it
particularly if a year has gone by if
two years have gone by
there's a serious likelihood that some
of that 64
would say you know i'm kind of over
trump i'm actually going to stay
but even if it's 20 or 30 or 40 percent
of the republican party
that does leave if trump starts his own
party
that could spell absolute and total
disaster for the republican party and it
would also mean that the republican
nominee would not be trump because trump
would be the nominee
of whatever party his starts that he
starts that's something that could
change
the other thing that could change is
that all of this energy around trump
much of it fomented by his claims for
two months after the election that joe
biden stole it and that he actually won
subsequently by continuing to claim and
being supported in his claims by newsmax
and oan and to some degree fox news
uh that he has this strategy or that
strategy to try to get the election back
that generated a lot of excitement
and a lot of interest and a lot of
energy if that simply dissipates
with trump out of the spotlight then you
could also see
um the party go in a different direction
that maybe would not choose trump as its
2024 nominee
and then also i think that this will
sort of be a feedback loop but
if trump sort of fades away a little bit
over the next 18 months
it's quite possible that many of the
trumpian elected officials that came to
power
only because of their affiliation with
trumpism i'm thinking about
marjorie taylor greene lauren beaubert
madison cawthorne and there are others
but those are sort of the big three
the trumpy elected officials may get
absolutely destroyed in their 2022
re-election campaigns i already saw
some early data and statements
out of marjorie taylor green's district
in uh georgia
that suggests it could be a bloodbath
for her
in november of 2022. it's so long from
now
it's very difficult to say for sure
we're you know 19 months away or
something like that
but if the trumpy elected officials get
crushed in 2022
that may kind of continue this decline
of trumpism within the republican party
but mitt romney is completely right as
of right now
donald trump would easily win the
republican nomination
and you know we talk about areas in
which democrats and republicans are too
similar
and areas in which democrats and
republicans couldn't be more different
donald trump
never could have won a democratic
primary
in 2016. never would have happened the
democratic electorate
simply would not be bamboozled in that
way you can say a lot of things about
elected
democrats and a lot of things about the
democratic electorate but they would
never
fall for someone like trump the
republican electorate
not only fell for it in 2016 they
continued to support him
in 2020 to almost the same degree he
ultimately did
lose the presidential election and so
far they still support him
that is a dramatic difference between
the democratic electorate and the
republican electorate in terms of what
they are capable of falling
for and at this point all we can do is
wait this sunday donald trump will make
his first public speech since leaving
office at cpac
we will be covering it live and i'm
curious to see if and what he says
if anything about uh the 2024 election
or even 2022
he is expected to talk about the his
future to some degree
within republican party politics so
that's i believe
in the three o'clock eastern hour on
sunday i'll be live on youtube twitch
and facebook
covering that i think you'll find this
super interesting
the term gaslighting has become very
tainted by a movement on the right to
claim
that the use of the term gaslighting is
in and of itself some kind of ruse
now the truth is that gaslighting is a
real thing sometimes the word
is applied correctly and sometimes it
isn't
but generally speaking gaslighting is a
form
of psychological manipulation in which a
person or a group
covertly sows seeds of doubt in a
targeted
individual or group making them question
their own memory perception or judgment
so simply lying about something telling
a lie
it doesn't really rise to the level of
being gaslighting
in spirit or even by the letter of what
it is
there has to be some kind of more
calculated manipulative intent
and last night on his fox news program
host tucker carlson
casually claimed that he and his team
weren't able to find any evidence
that q anon and q even exist
or that they have a following or that
they're a thing
and part of the reason he says that he
doesn't believe they exist is that he
didn't find an official
q a on website which of course if you
know anything about q anon you would
understand well they don't have a
website
uh if you haven't if somehow you're not
aware of q anon
i envy you q anon is a disproven right
wing conspiracy theory
which claims that there's a secret cabal
of satan worshiping
pedophiles running a global child sex
trafficking ring and that they plotted
against donald trump sometimes hillary
is involved sometimes not and that
donald trump
was sent to be president to root out
these horrible people supporters of q
anon
include white nationalists and other
far-right extremists and of course they
were
major supporters of donald trump and
uh they were big players
in continuing to sow the false stories
of so-called
voter fraud and election fraud in the
time after
the 2020 presidential election now the
people who believe in this stuff
and support trump through it definitely
exist they're obviously wrong on the
facts but
tucker here says we can't find any
evidence that this is even a thing
and this is a perfect example of
gaslighting let's take a look at the
video
so it's worth finding out where the
public is getting all this false
information this
disinformation as we'll call it so we
checked
we spent all day trying to locate the
famous q anon
which in the end we learned is not even
a website if it's out there we could not
find it
then we checked marjorie taylor green's
twitter feed because we have heard she
trafficks in disinformation seen and
told us
but nothing there so tucker learned
that q anon doesn't have a website
well we we knew that he says he couldn't
find
q anon nor any evidence of
disinformation
posted by marjorie taylor green ever
this is truly gaslighting first of all
you know the whole idea of cue from the
beginning was
they don't have a website there's no q
anon gazette there's no
you know q report equivalent of the
drudge report where they post their
ideas and articles
the whole concept was this is a here's a
term
this is a sub rosa thing where
there's supposedly an insider providing
the information
posting it to obscure internet forums
and it's
uh repeated or signal boosted by the
followers of q
so this is a red herring and it is gas
lighting tucker not
finding a website isn't evidence for or
against anything
now mind you tucker is the same guy
who says he mailed physical flash drives
without having backed up the content
across the country during his so-called
investigation of hunter biden
so he's not necessarily the brightest
guy when it comes to these
investigations
and informational security but okay now
the extra gas lighting
is tucker and fox news have actually
been major amplifiers
themselves of election related
disinformation which plays right into
the entire q perspective and they're
being sued at this point for it
for repeating some of the same claims
coming from the q anon wing
of the republican party including that
donald trump actually won
the 2020 election now in terms of you
know the marjorie taylor green thing
he says we looked at marjorie taylor
green's twitter we didn't find any
disinformation ever
um that's a laughable joke and she's
promoted cue stuff for a very long time
but you don't need to go back very far
just look at the stuff she's posted over
the last 24 to 36 hours
this morning marjorie taylor green
tweeted quote democrats are so beholden
to the abortion murder lobby and their
blood money campaign contributions
that they nominate a guy becerra for
health and human services
who's fine with murdering babies up
until the day they are born
and maybe even after that's not
disinformation
come on and then also spreading
disinformation
about january 6 itself tweeting speaker
pelosi have you figured out who
planted the pipe bombs at the rnc in the
dnc on january 5th
the night before the capital attack on
january 6
showing the attack was planned and not
incited by press
incited by president trump and directed
at both
republicans and democrats that's just
the last 24 to 36 hours
and she's been spreading and repeating q
anon stuff
for month after month after month this
is gaslighting
what tucker carlson did is gaslighting
making his viewers
question their reality maybe q anon
doesn't even exist
in in which case by the way it would
make
everything that democrats are saying a
lie
which is exactly the idea that populist
tucker carlson wants to promulgate on
his program
that's gaslighting and unfortunately
you have a really willing audience a
really eager audience
to follow whatever tucker carlson says
on his program
remember tucker carlson's lawyers fox
news lawyers used when defending tucker
carlson in lawsuits
they used as a defense tucker carlson
shouldn't be interpreted as telling the
truth
he's doing hyperbole and he's doing
entertainment he's not actually
reporting facts on his program that's
what lawyers
said under oath uh not under oath uh inc
the lawyers aren't underwrote in court
proceedings
defending the statements of tucker
carlson just remember that when you
watch this program
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we've been continuing to follow all of
the different ways in which donald trump
is likely to be tied up
with lawyers legal fees potentially in
depositions
of possible criminal investigations and
so much more and more and more it's
likely to be
years and years of this and it's
conceivable that donald trump may soon
have to actually
answer questions about the rape
allegations against him
under oath and this relates to e gene
carroll you
may remember that e gene carroll
accused donald trump of having raped her
in a manhattan department store in the
mid-1990s
and when this became a story
in 2019 donald trump said
he never knew egyne carroll accused her
of lying to sell a new
book and added that she's not my type
well now her lawyers have filed a
defamation suit
against donald trump and in fact they
filed that suit
some time ago but not much was happening
partially
because donald trump was still president
of the united states
now this is actually moving forward the
explanation of trump is president and
this can't move forward for the time
being
because he's president and it would be
in some way damaging or
prejudicial for it to move forward that
is no longer a defense
and eg and carol's lawyers are looking
to
depose donald trump in this
defamation suit and an attorney for
trump
is not returning requests for comment
about
this particular case but it is
conceivable that in the next could be
six months could be 12 months could be
18 months
donald trump would actually have to
under oath answer
questions about the alleged rape
that egyne carroll says took place this
is not
the only case in which donald trump may
have to answer questions under oath
about an alleged sexual assault that
he's accused of
there is a similar defamation lawsuit
from summer zervos that's
again a name that may ring a bell she
was a contestant
on trump's reality show the apprentice
and back in 2016
zervos also accused donald trump of
sexual misconduct
saying that it took place in 2007
initially um when they were at a meeting
in new york
and then later he groped her at a
california
hotel when they were supposedly meeting
to discuss
job opportunities trump not only denied
that but also said zervos is a liar
and so zervos sued donald trump for
defamation in 2017. similarly that did
not really go
anywhere because donald trump was
president at the time
and there is again the renewed belief
that that may indeed
be moving forward soon now
um legal experts have said
that the idea of um
the interference that the justice
department ran for trump on a lot of
these cases while he was pre
a president is unprecedented
and um that that is not the way that any
other president has been treated
while in office but that while still
academically interesting is in the past
the question now
becomes are these cases going to move
forward and
is trump even as a former president uh
going to be compelled
to be deposed and we don't know the
answer yet but it will be
extraordinarily interesting to follow
and see now
if you just zoom out of this for a
moment um
it is truly another indicator
of the two-tier justice system that we
have that donald trump
it's not even at this point that trump
hasn't been held accountable
for any of the things that he's done
they've not been adjudicated
right even if you believe that you're
and as
we all should that you are innocent
until proven guilty
there's no adjudications that are even
on the table because donald trump has
been able to avoid
even responding to these claims donald
trump has not been deposed when it comes
to
these complaints and he's not been put
under oath he's not even had to step
foot
in court for anything so it's just
another reminder that there really are
two justice systems and that having
power having money having friends in
high places having obviously
uh being in the most privileged position
of power that one could arguably be in
in the world as president of the united
states laws
only matter if there's somebody willing
to enforce them and one of the things we
learned
big picture from the trump presidency
is that the systems that the founding
fathers put in place
um as checks and balances to a president
for a president against the president
relative to a president
uh arguably weren't strong enough
because as soon as you had a president
willing to ignore and to flaunt his
power
and to flout the norms and checks and
balances
nothing happened now you could make the
case well the problem isn't the system
the problem is that trump had the
republican party
um willing to help him avoid
consequences well
then that's just part of the problems
with the system the system should be
the checks and balances should be robust
enough
that you don't have to depend on a
weaponized
friendly republican party to keep
a republican president out of actually
um
having to face the allegations against
them so
that that's the way it is if you have
money and if you have lawyers who can
just
tie things up with paperwork you can
burden just about any system endlessly
and keep yourself out of harm's way and
um as we see you come at trump and then
he may sue you uh and then if you
try to sue trump for defamation then
he'll just figure out a way to avoid
being deposed and a lot of this
hopefully
was only because he was president we
will see
we will see i'm not like super
optimistic i have to say
we covered i think it was two weeks ago
the very healthy incomes
of jared kushner and his wife ivanka
trump
while they were working in the white
house
earning some 400 million or so dollars
between the two of them
again remember while they were advising
donald trump on policy and
ivanka was meeting with world leaders
sitting in for the secretary of state
we now have income data for donald trump
and donald trump
is and this is the key word donald trump
is admitting to
making more than 1.6 billion dollars in
revenue and income
during his four years as president of
the united states that's roughly
400 million dollars per year this is
based on a review
by crew citizens for responsible
ethics watchdog i doubt that's what it
is i always forget what crew stands for
but they're a very good organization
that has reviewed donald trump's
financial disclosures
and donald trump very publicly took
credit for and bragged about
donating his salary uh 440 000
a year i believe it is but that ended up
representing less than 0.1 percent of
the revenue and
income that he has disclosed during his
presidency so
really no big sacrifice and i think that
there's a couple of different stories
here
on the one hand donald trump's
presidency did significant damage to his
brand reputation
lots of things removing the trump name
from them
buildings condo buildings etc donald
trump's hospitality revenue
down dramatically many of his hotels
even before the pandemic doing
not well the pandemic has only
accelerated that of course
but at the same time you have to
understand
that there are all sorts of other
sources of revenue for donald trump
including licensing and other properties
that trump has an
interest in but don't have the trump
name on them
many people may not even know that
they're necessarily trump-affiliated
properties
golf courses and so many other things
some of these are in europe we know of
course of turnberry
in uh and aberdeen in scotland two of
donald trump's golf courses there
and this has been a very profitable
presidency for donald trump donald trump
and his family
repeatedly said we're sort of taking a
you know we're taking a hit here
my life was great before with being
president and you know i was making all
sorts of money and i'm
separating myself from all these
businesses and all of this stuff
made a big show of putting a big stack
of papers in front of him
during the transition period in 2016
claiming that
uh he he is going to be disassociating
himself from all of these businesses
well
turns out that he still earned a ton a
ton of money
and what this really makes me think of
is the
stunning hypocrisy with which
right wingers can honestly say
bernie has a million dollars at nearly
80 years old
and after earning six figures for
decades as a member of congress and now
the senate
bernie has a million dollars in three
houses
donald trump earned 400 million dollars
per year
while president of the united states
jimmy carter when he was president
severed ties with his family's peanut
farm
to avoid even the possibility of the
appearance
of the perception of impropriety and
donald trump made
400 million dollars per year and you
hear
nothing from his followers it shouldn't
really surprise us
and then the last thing is as of course
with trump
he's admitting to 1.6 billion while
president
how much else is there and with donald
trump
we know he's very willing to say that a
particular building
is worth a lot if he needs to use it as
collateral
for a loan or not worth much at all
if it's to reduce the value of his
assets for tax purposes
uh real estate tax purposes or whatever
the case may be
donald trump is admitting to 1.6 million
in income and revenue while he was
president
what else is there how much has been
funneled to his various kids we know
that with campaign donations he was
regularly
putting his uh family members on staff
lara trump and many many others
we may never know the full scope of it
sadly we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
i've heard from so many people about
these bogus claims that windmills wind
farms don't work in cold weather
here is one such voicemail i received
making some very good points
hi david my name is prince i live in
california yes
you were talking about ted cruz and his
mind ass i'm sorry and then lying
about the uh the power grid you'd be
ready to mention that
the uh win windmills are working in
alaska
yes where it's very cold all the time
and solar power
works in space like in mars and
in the space shuttle where it's like
minus 300 degrees
so the cold does not affect it the same
way
correct thank you yeah i mean listen you
don't need to go to mars
or nars as donald trump used to call it
you don't need to go to outer space or
alaska
um wyoming and montana have properly
winterized
wind turbines they work fine
um uh it's it it is a ruse
that it is merely because of green
energy as we know the vast majority of
the failures in texas during the storms
were
natural gas coal and nuclear caused by
lack of winterization
uh this happened in 2011 a report was
compiled which said
here's how you winterize all of these
types of energy power generation
mechanisms it wasn't done the same thing
happened in 2021
it's it's that simple we have a great
bonus show for you today
we have news about the third coronavirus
vaccine and we will discuss that
lawmakers are now targeting the video
game
grand theft auto because of an increase
in real world carjackings
what we're doing this again plus how can
they come after grand theft auto it's
like the only video game that i liked
playing growing up as a kid
okay and then tiger woods was in a
single car accident
i'm not so much going to talk about the
accident i'm going to talk about
whether that's really news and what it
means about the news cycle
that it was so widely covered you can
probably guess some of the questions
we'll be asking
and there are probably more uh
discussions to be had there as well
all of those stories on today's bonus
show
get instant access to the bonus show you
know how to do it
you go to join pacman.com you sign up
you hit the b you hit the big red sign
up button and within seconds you will be
listening to
or watching today's bonus show i'll see
you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground